and you ready let's do it one two three
[Music]
windows up drive it like you stole it
[Music]
officer twerk what happened I got a dude
in my car that the whole world is
watching our nation's first orcish
police officer I can't [ __ ] up my
pension hey don't get me stabbed wire
voice always gotta be the bad guys so
that night we responded to a 415
disturbance car immediately took five
right no holes only the ones I was born
are your holes the [ __ ] can you make a
shootout awkward
there's a magic wand it's like a new
killer weapon that grants wishes and it
just went really sideways from that
point it's all missing magic strong and
kill we have to protect the wand so I
need to know if that you got my back you
cop first or in pork first it's time to
end this [ __ ] it I want it done let's do
it we're gonna titty bar gunfight dive
the nightmares
feels like a dog on the piece of
something
a lot of fingers we were doing so good
Oh refreshed I think we should spend our
time just trying to survive this year
[Music]
we'll be heroes forever
I need you to take your fat Shrek
looking ass back a [ __ ] home to Fiona
all right
you
you